I can't celebrate yet but he is at least
tied for the lead here at the Ziegfeld
Cup in fact far from celebrating as
these games are still hotly contested we
won't know for some time but sitting in
close to he cannot be overtaken at least
so minimum he has a playoff in the
pocket
Fabiana when you came to the game today
what were you considering oh he said
yesterday that he would go all out I was
expecting something like what he played
I mean it was just such a dull game
nothing really happened I was expecting
him to try something better because he
it was kind of a must-win for him you
know he didn't really want to play
tonight not much you could do with about
that with the black pieces now you sit
in a situation where you have to wait to
see what happens your thoughts on that
but both games which are very critical
or extremely exciting I mean this is
terribly damaged for Hikaru but it's
probably objectively okay
and I'm goofs game is also very
interesting play I assume let alone
won't take the exchange which is on
offer and then it might not be as
interesting but Hikaru will have to play
extremely well to survive this is
another game remember girls game as well
but it looks like but yeah white is just
pleasantly better so so shock is not
going to win and I mean unless an
accident happened by I suspect that
shock will not win that position often
you've been in a situation where you
you're tied but you guaranteed yourself
at least the type at first you had to
sit around and wait what does that feel
like not too often actually I can
remember the last time cuz in London it
was other way around I I had to win to
to tie with with Yummie Yummie Tommy she
and I had to play like a six hour game
while he was waiting around and now it's
the reverse I think there is a pretty
decent chance so alone plus two but I I
don't know maybe maybe it's a 50% chance
someone will win one of these games
because they're both sharpened and both
greased you can Aronian have winning
chances in their game so there are three
players who could potentially go on plus
two you're not renowned for your rapid
and blitz kills as one of the bests
in the world at least by rating what is
your feeling about the playoffs going
into that if it does happen I'm it would
be very interesting that a playoff but I
still would prefer to win clear first
without meaning to to play anymore chess
because after after the last like two
weeks or so I am pretty much saturated
with chess all right well we hope to get
you back in this chair again and I'm
sure you'd prefer like you said to get
back as the winner otherwise we're gonna
see you tomorrow so give me a chance to
wait and see how these games go thanks
Abbie because